[Music]
[Applause]
and we make way for the NFL Network host
and also Michigan grad or maybe it
should be Michigan grad and NFL Network
host Rich Eisen rich I mean if you're
looking for the right words Dan to
introduce me just call me National
Champion Rich Eisen okay you know what
I'm saying if you don't mind National
Champion is that okay with you all right
uh you more likely to do it more likely
or less likely to lose your head coach
because of a national
championship um I think more likely uh I
think it was likely either way um
straight up but you never know with Jim
Harbaugh I do not know I have no earthly
idea um what what he will consider most
important everything you hear coming out
of Ann Arbor is that it won't be money
that keeps him coming back uh to
Michigan it would be the search of
putting in Lombard in his trophy case um
The elusive one and um we'll also find
out uh again the thing his setup in Ann
Arbor is um to his liking not just
professionally but apparently he lives
next door to his parents who can come by
and see the grandkids he feeds his
chickens in the backyard when the kids
the the uh when the students come by uh
he's already turned around his thought
apparently about eating chicken once
upon a time it was a nervous bird now
he's eating chicken again I have no idea
nobody knows um but I would just guess
that obviously mission accomplished
that's what he was coming back to school
to do he has accomplished that mission
and um if he moves on uh it would be
totally understandable how do you
respond to the haters who think that
this title is Tainted I mean should I
respond to them in the same one of my
favorite uh sound bites from our from
our Sports Center years Dan was uh
Patrick W saying I can't I can't hear
you with my ring in my ear you know what
I mean I mean like that's that's the
answer the haters come on man I mean
seriously um the the proverbial usually
um when people or teams or athletes
coaches win championships and say no one
can take it away from us there's the
NCAA they might attempt to take it away
from us this entire time uh that has
been percolating uh but let them try um
and Charles wson said it on my show when
I had him on after the roseb victory I I
if if people talk about asterisks or
tainted as I know you guys have on the
program um that the bottom line is I'll
just put on my national championship hat
and my shirt and go about my business
I'm not used to being the villain Dan
I'm not used to rooting for a team and
being the villain um I'm learning on the
Fly um and so that's the way I'm going
with it right now well we've had we had
Michigan callers a few yesterday and uh
I said well how would you feel if this
was Ryan day at Ohio State and they were
going through this would you be as
lenient as you objective as you want
everybody else to be with Michigan Jim
Harbaugh Connor stallions well you know
what I mean a shoe on the other foot I
mean I've been there and done that I had
my ass kicked by Ohio State for so long
and um of course I would be viewing it
completely differently I'm not going to
lie and say that uh my objectivity uh in
the Michigan Ohio States
uh rivalry wouldn't affect my you know
my thought process of course um you know
but the bottom line is the script is
entirely flipped you know like a George
Burns Body switching 80s movie dan like
we are now in Ohio State's body they are
in the Michigan body that uh for years
Dan how many times did I come on your
program in the early years of Harbaugh
and you're asking me can Jim do it is he
going to be able to do it do you want
him out yeah you've you've put me on
many different uh well when they were
two and four Rich during the pandemic
and they told him to take a pay cut I
wasn't the only one asking that question
no no I'm but I'm just pointing out as
we're sitting here in this forum the
number of times where I I I was um asked
uncomfortable questions and I'm not
saying they were not legitimate of
course they were but I I I it was a
tough time it was a tough time and I
heard from Ohio State fans all the time
I heard from Ohio State players uh
coming on this program I heard about it
all the time and now I don't hear very
much and it's awesome it is truly
awesome at this point in time three
straight years making the
national um championship playoffs and
now the national championship game and
winning it all uh it is it is a spike
the football moment sure to the haters
but just in general to the millions upon
Millions upon millions of Michigan fans
that are out there that have been
waiting and generations have been
waiting because this is better than 97
97 was beat Washington State and then
have an argument this is now you know
the argument is is there an asterisk is
there taint whatever who knows I don't I
don't know and I don't care because for
sure what we saw against Alabama and
what we saw against Ohio State before
that and what we saw against Washington
is a deeper more talented team and a
better coached team winning snap to snap
quarter to quarter and then game to game
and that I I don't think you can dispute
that no I can't the performance but
it'll be disputed that somebody was
doing something and it benefited
somebody uh so I I I think you know the
NCAA is going to take five years to get
around to this Jim Harbaugh might be on
his second job after leaving Michigan
maybe he's back at Michigan but I just
think that they're they're going to have
to look at this and say we suspended did
you for six games now they're two
separate incidents but you know you sat
down for three and you said you were
fighting it then you didn't that to me
was a Telltale sign if he fought it
great I don't want to have you know this
hanging over Michigan they were a great
team this year but there's still some
baggage that is there and it doesn't fit
in the overhead bin I don't think we're
ever going to find out what Conor
stallion's Legion of phone
video were were actually put in the
hands of somebody and actually
pinpointed to a moment where Michigan
won a down uh I mean the when when this
all happened Dan the video that came out
of CJ strad pre snap uh in a game
against Michigan and you could see
behind him Michigan Defenders or kids on
the sideline jumping and pointing to the
sky and stallions was whispering in the
ears of the defensive coordinator and
the coach at the time everyone was like
there it is like the Rick Dalton GIF
from Once Upon a Time in Hollywood there
it is that's it and then when you
actually look at the play CJ strad
scored on that drive let me tell you
this Dan the number of times that
apparently Conor stallions cheated to
Michigan's success against Ohio State I
wish that would have put me in a rocking
chair much sooner than they did on the
actual day when Michigan was actually
down at halftime is that what it was
like the the the cheating they were just
holding back just enough for Michigan to
not lead by halftime and again Dan how
many times have you been on vacation
with your beautiful family and you're
standing there in one a wonderful Vista
and uh you're maybe taking a selfie I
don't know if you're a selfie guy and
then somebody goes hey let me take this
photograph for you and you hand them
your phone and they take like forever to
shoot the C and then they hand you back
your phone and the photograph is
Thoroughly unusable like there's no
chance you're thinking in your head is
the photograph's being taken this is
going to be the holiday card I sent to
Rich and Susie and everyone else and uh
you know and and that's how I'll swap
family cards with the burmans you know
and so bottom line is you get handed
back an unusable photograph so every
video that Conor stallion's minions took
was not only pristine and perfect and
captured exactly what they were looking
for but it wound up in the proper hands
to be used at the proper time to the
best effect listen that's for the haters
and that's for the NCAA to figure out
but Jim sat down for six games and he
did sit down for three and the three
most difficult ones including one where
he found out he was being sat on the
flight out on a day that courts were
closed and Michigan couldn't push back
because it was a national holiday
purposeful who knows for another day
bottom line is there's a banner there's
a ring and that Banner will always fly
in Michigan Stadium and I can never ever
ever thank and repay these kids and the
coaches and the staff of Michigan enough
cuz it has been an incredible run
incredible talking to a Michigan grad
Rich Eisen NFL Network host you couldn't
tell no could not tell all right um if
you had to guess on Bill bich yeah what
would you it would be oh it would be
parting ways I think and going where I
don't know that I have no earthly idea
nobody does if you're the NFL where
would you want to place him uh
Washington DC okay put him in the money
division have him take on the Giants his
old team twice a year um have him um you
know hooked up with a generationally
talented quarterback uh at this stage of
his career in the same way Greg papovich
has been hooked up with wanyama at this
part of his career um let him go against
Dallas twice a year on Thanksgiving once
in a while let him go into Philadelphia
um and try and bring the commanders back
to prominence um in late windows on Fox
as much as possible against the like
that's if you're the league I think
that's where you would pinpoint his
location next I saw where the ratings
for the entire season for the NFL were
up 7% MH and that's hard to do because I
don't know where you're getting your
audience from and I don't know how much
ratings matter to the NFL from the
standpoint of you have Amazon on
Thursday night you're going to have
peacock streaming this playoff game yeah
so I don't know like they sent the
message out up 7% but then I don't know
if ratings matter to the NFL I know they
matter to their Partners but but you
know is that a interesting number to you
if I if I had to guess again the
international series obviously I'm
biased because I call most of those
games but I I think fans dig that early
fourth window I think East Coast Fans
dig that 9:30 3 a.m. kick on certain
weeks and I think uh Christmas Eve night
triple headers on Saturday double
headers on ESPN on back-to-back
Saturdays um because I think the NFL's
been really smart in placing their
markers on weekends when college
football is done with its regular season
and its Conference Championship season
and kind of seeds the ground to get
ready for the Once Upon a Time Most
Wonderful Time of the Year here um the
NFL is kind of sneaking in there um that
Friday game on Amazon the the Black
Friday game that I think is going to be
uh Huger and Huger every year uh if I
had a guess that's probably where the
audiences came from all right if if I
said that you could win a sports Emmy
okay or Jim Harbaugh goes back to
Michigan you can't have both only one
you and your show okay win a sports Emmy
or Jim Harbaugh comes back to Michigan
now my guys are hearing this question
around me Dan so you said me and then
you said my show well it's your
show but it's your your your crew there
too okay so my crew would be honored as
well as yes it'd be the Rich Eisen show
okay no you said I would win an Emmy so
again because you know and get it you'd
go get I'm halfway to Susan Luchi in
terms of the sports host you know what I
mean like that you know I I I I sit in
uh in starving and thirsty for three and
a half hours until they finally announce
that award every year yeah but it never
changed my life when I won a sports Emy
so I'm just telling you it it won't
change your life but it could
[Laughter]
change uh you'd like to find out if
it'll change walk down the street and
say that's the guy you finally beat too
or answer the question
it's the guy who finally beat your crew
your crew wants you to answer would you
rather the
show on the sports Emmy or jimb comes
back to michig I would rather the show
winning Emmy instead of Jim Harbaugh
coming back to Michigan okay all right I
know if you see what I'm doing at the
same time no no it's not that's not
working you're Shak in your head that
that they okay sorry to lie
detector your radio audience out of joke
look you yeah look at you yeah what
moves you what do does any sports team
move you in the same way that Michigan
moves me are you are you out of that
game d i' I've been out of that game
since I went to
ESPN what do you mean it's called being
a journalist
Rich it's called being a journalist all
right being a Jour but but shows like
this Dan it's called The Dan Patrick
Show it's not called the journalism show
that Dan Patrick you they want people
fans want to know what you think and
moves you and what what moves me is a
great story right I don't I don't have
any rooting Allegiance anymore none for
anything no no you don't watch a Bengals
game no I'm trying to choose any from oh
again Ohio State against Michigan no I
you don't deep down Route against
Michigan Dan deep
down I I was hoping Michigan would win
when they beat him a couple ago
yes if Ohio State keeps beating Michigan
it's not a
rivalry I'm glad that Michigan
won I am okay it's better for the story
it's all about the story Rich I'm a
Storyteller is what I am I thought
you're a tapestry Weaver no quite
frankly that's what you do is you weave
weave I'm a Tom raly kind of
Storyteller oh God the slow Fox music is
that what you're saying we play music
going to break gota be a piano whenever
whenever you see Tom raldi and he's got
a piano behind him somebody died
somebody died Here Comes Tom R oh he's
got the piano no but if he comes without
the piano you're like let's do that sit
down you know what I mean I'll tell you
my story but he brings the piano that's
the same guy you don't want to be the
the player when they play the slow Fox
music to break you are you getting a
Michigan tattoo just like Jim Harbaugh
is no I'm not getting a tattoo Dan but
I'm going to get my Championship hat in
my shirt and I will wear it proudly
amongst all the haters what would what
the haters oh there it is okay hey hey
you haters out there hey you haters out
there not lyrics you
you no that's no I'll send you the
lyrics Dan I'll send you the lyrics yeah
okay it is a great fight song and a and
a great helmet thanks for giving me that
yeah so congratulations and in 5 years
I'll have you on the oh I won't be doing
the show when they take away the
banner I'll have you on mine then okay
that'll be good I'll come on your show
all right you're always welcome that's
Rich Eisen he host the Rich Eisen show
on Roku and of course NFL he's got a
busy busy weekend coming up are you
working Saturday and Sunday Rich St I'm
working as many days as I possibly can
blood from the stone there I love it I'm
there for I'm there for America I love
it I love it um all right we'll come
back uh we'll get your phone calls my
thanks to Rich Eisen there uh Michigan
grad by the way take a break back after
[Music]
this